Now we just said that points B and D, are special because they represent a
switch in the direction of the slope of the function. Now speaking of general
behavior of the function, I'd like you to tell me, what its domain is and what
its range is. Now please note that even though I've written y equals this time
instead of F of x equals. This is to remind you that the reason an equation is a
function is not because of what we choose to call the dependent variable. It's
because of the way that this expression over here involving x's maps the inputs
to the output. This is in fact a function, and we can write that in a more
technical way by saying y equals f of x. In other words the real function of x
is this expression over here. The one that's taking all the inputs of x and
modifying them to create the output which is y. Just on the side to make sure
you understand the notation here, what purpose it serves and how all these
different things are connected. So back to the function itself, please write the
domain and the range using interval notation in these two boxes.